hola when you were in college you could
play video games to your thumbs fell off
but when you move home uh not so much
södra pose to Susan yo didn't give her a
ring yeah he made her a violin come on
and she still knew it was a proposal oh
yeah you'd never show challenge me get
ready to pay up the only thing I'm gonna
be paying a visit to is you in the
hospital when I break your face Yeah
right bro All Right game time is over
sweetie mom it's the fourth quarter well
I don't care if it's the fifth quarter
the ladies book club is gonna be here in
minutes we're reading my book wow you
think of look great job I wrote it i'm
sarah i wrote a book i do not sound like
that Michael stop mocking your sister
it's the third of a trilogy I'm
impressed with this chicken here Michael
I was talking to the game I'm not losing
that is enough come on last play come on
mom no what are you doing that was the
last play of the game yeah it was my
house my rules your father and I are the
adults around here whoa touchdown yeah
by your old man I have intense again
controller yeah who'd never played the
game you stupid right now Oh never just
a controller I've got to get my own
place hey Michael your dad is beating
you at video games news flash it's time
to move out seriously get your own place
due to use to living at home with your
parents we're here to help enter the
Comedy Central growing up and getting
out contest you could win rent for a
year presented by KFC original recipe
bites bite-sized chicken is all grown up